because I only want to break us the only
job I have every day is to wake up and
put this company out of business by us
being the ones that put ourselves out of
business versus letting somebody out
there or do it for us here I go talking
about the same thing you no matter what
I say if you want me to change to the
sky
the entire group so unlike
some daisies so feeling but mostly I
would rather be blind
what you do
that's right
I have to run to this meeting I love you
so much being able to do stuff yeah
exactly that's totally the best part I
think of that kind of transition house
the house really well yeah
good morning hey quick conversation I
was the same like all the changes that
were happening everything was going on
and like you're saying let's grab a
bunch of people ask questions and that
kind of thing so you're here I'm here
you know there's a lot of things that
this company doesn't have permission for
and a lot of things that it does by the
nature of how we grew the market puts
you into the category that you come from
like a lot of people are cynical to us
we run our media we win it they eat crow
and we build momentum because we have a
lot of audacity we're new and when we
win yay there is no winning like there
is but the number really sees itself
through and is black and white one of
the things that are gonna be written
it's gonna be very interesting in
reframing creative at Boehner is I think
that I took the ROI conversation a
little too far to the point where
especially people have worked here for
two years or longer or even 18 months I
feel like everybody from top like in
accounting and legal it's like what's
the ROI and and I think that what that's
done is it's pushed us too far down the
path of sales and not enough towards
marketing so I think a
you've got to set up your conversation
for success with a client upfront like
you know the amount of things I do for
my brand why my gray that has no clear
black and white KPI and that the KPI is
the learnings from the campaign itself
to then decide what to do with it if I
want to do it again or never again so I
think I think there's two ways to think
about it one is has to learn what can we
get from it that we can build on top of
or a conversation of you know what does
the amplification around it mean to the
brand I mean like there's so many so I'm
at James Corden right before he started
the The Late Late Show whenever he's on
right and literally at a dinner he
talked about like carpool karaoke in the
same way he talked about 43 other things
I didn't know which one would change his
career but that was the one I don't
think right this minute but I do think
in 2017 one it's funny you said that I
think and by the way not right this
minute mainly because I'm running this
business at such a low margin there's a
lot of young people coming up the system
who just on pure talent habit and
ironically you'll find this fascinating
if you asked me what I would lean more
towards it would be my preference that's
somebody that worked here for two years
and came up the ACC track right leapfrog
I'd rather hire a lot of the senior
people we've hired
I'd rather hire them slot it in and
maintain that thing because we need it
and have the junior talent leapfrog that
would actually do better now I'm not
gonna do that to them either they
equally have the same thing but it's
unbelievable how much I'm feeling of why
this is gonna work I have no rationale
whatsoever I have vested interest in any
direction other than what does the best
for the logo because it's talent not you
- I think that's culture Ike I created a
culture where early on it was like hey
hire us for this 25k a month
micro-content will never asked more
incremental will be the best in the
sandbox
- say yes to everything and nothing
again those unique things were why we
grew faster than anybody but they're
definitely legacy things that now hurt
us with your winery things one of the
reasons you want to meet me
the amount of times that I've made ship
way better in the third quarter like the
amount of games I've been losing twenty
seven to three and a half time and then
one a lot and I think I think that's way
better than not getting on the field
yes yes that's right and I'll tell you
if you're in a place where your journal
bound and doing less of the alternative
how old are you perfect you're at the
point now where why don't you just take
three years and just do and see what
that tastes like cuz you know what
[ __ ] feeling journals taste like I
think it's much smarter for you to talk
to the world about your process of going
through this then the advice that you
shake think you should be giving them
and that's where people are struggling I
I got real lucky I've never said this
d-roc so pay real close [ __ ]
attention I'm not sure that if the
internet was around in its current form
that I would be as successful because at
22 and 23 I knew I was special and I
might have not been patient enough to
first build a business first get
experience I didn't start talking to the
world so I was 35
and I love to say to you be patient to
you to be patient I'm not sure if I
would have been I'd like to think I
would have been but the freedom of
pudding-like I love to hear myself talk
like like that
you know and I think anybody that a spot
like think about so do you and so
there's so many of you like that's what
it is and it's nice there's nothing
wrong with that it sounds bad it's funny
a lot of what I deal with now is being
okay with not being politically correct
work-life balance Herzing whatever let
meritocracy you know I don't know if
you've seen this do you see that I was
on The Breakfast Club so I don't know if
you watch that interview or some of the
content that I've been building on I'm
on a hot no excuses kick I have a lot of
female entrepreneurs I have a lot of
fans that are African Americans I spent
a lot of time and that community my
college years I just think I'm giving
the best advice to women and minorities
in business today which is tough
and it's crazy like you have to
understand in my body right now it
doesn't feel great it feels a lot better
going somewhere else the problem is it's
the truth
like the market just doesn't care and
what's cool is when you actually say
[ __ ] it then you start betting on your
strengths I got to tell you like I don't
know the code Nicole college business
model is the most fascinating so you
know and that's the point right you're
literally paying and I genuinely believe
in marketing there's not a school right
now teaching anything that's right
they're just not how many of you learn
marketing classes what does it look like
right so like [ __ ] me anyway I think the
best thing you should do they listen to
be very frank with you bro honestly I
think you're about to start the part of
your life where you gonna learn
where it matters on the field right I
may throw you guys for a loop on this
one I actually think you should just
enjoy the living [ __ ] out of this last
year I'm not kidding like you know if
your app if you're me well then you'd be
selling [ __ ] and starting a business on
the side anyway but if you're not like
dying to do that like I wouldn't have
gone to a [ __ ] internship like so
like like like I'm like I was broken
like I could only do it my what you know
like I'm barely even went to my dad's
liquor store like I was making $3,000 a
weekend selling baseball cards when I
was 14 like I was good like so I think
that my intuition is if you even have
this internship right that the real
answer is [ __ ] don't fail I guess
because maybe your parents would be
upset but then like I don't know like
and if you want to learn I think you'll
learn more the truth is unless you start
your own business which will take a lot
of time which I'm trying to debate is
that valuable to you in your last year
when you should probably milk this
ridiculous year that you're living which
many may think is the greatest single
year of your life right other than that
you're going to learn more in the first
hundred days of your job coming out then
they're so like to me it's just it's a
bet to like betting on strengths and
weaknesses though the value exchange
here feels like [ __ ]
just you know how are we gonna
differentiate in five years are we gonna
do VR stuff how are we gonna be
different I think the reason will always
be special especially if I'm really
controlling it and by the way I don't
know if I'm gonna be CEO for 15 years 3
19 as long as I'm the CEO we're gonna
win because I'm really good at buying
underpriced attention right so like the
way we're gonna differentiate is the way
we differentiate today which is we just
fundamentally understand the current
state of marketing better than others
and so that's it like that's the easiest
question for me to answer because I
don't know anything other of course we
are of course they are of course it's
the thing that Karen in Tulsa Okla you
know right now inventing that's gonna be
important in three years yes because I
only want to break us the only job I
have every day is to wake up and put
this company out of business by us being
the ones that put ourselves out of
business versus letting somebody out
there do it for us
got it so we'll only innovate you guys
heard all hands-on the only thing I can
promise is change I don't like change
get the [ __ ] out because this is not
gonna be a good place for you because
it's the only norm and and just so you
know at scale big companies 100 people
10 million in revenue that gets hard
people don't like change
you're on a little bit of the younger
side but even your own DNA may not like
change change is what most people hate
definitely after a certain period in
your life mid-thirties
hate and even 50% of this young crew
hate because it's hardwired change is
hard